[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
nella mia vita ho imparato ad essere la
pioniera di molte cose e ho imparato
anche che non è così male e anche
divertente in fondo non è così difficile
ecco io corre 100 metri ma quest'anno
l'avvicinamento alla paralimpiadi di rio
avvenuta a settembre è stata un po come
una maratona e se volete come una
traversata nel deserto
ecco la mia vita io ce l'avevo lì su
questo poster attaccata in camera col
cristo redentore di rio a guardare la
città quasi come se fosse qualcosa di
molto lontano e irraggiungibile un
miraggio
e come ogni traversata che si rispetti
anche la mia è stata piena di imprevisti
e di sofferenze credo di aver versato
così tante lacrime quest'anno da poter
far crescere qualcosa persino nel
deserto ebbene a gennaio del 2016
ho cominciato a sentire che mio fisico
mi dava segni di cedimento
ma io o guerriero non ha voluto mollare
perché gli allenamenti erano forti erano
pesanti e quindi ho continuato per poi
ritrovarmi a febbraio a fare i conti con
la realtà ovvero con un problema alla
gamba la mia gamba amputata che
praticamente era un problema sconosciuto
ai più e non si capiva che cosa fosse ma
non mi consentiva più di portare nella
protesi da cammino nella protesi da
corsa che io negli anni ero abituato ad
usare e quindi potete immaginare un
ritorno al passato come nove anni fa
quando ho avuto il mio incidente
stradale e mi son ritrovata di nuovo ad
essere disabile disarmata a non poter
più fare quello che stavo facendo e
quindi è tornata quella rabbia è tornata
a quelli impotenza e soprattutto non
potevo fare nulla ero costretta ad
aspettare
ero pensavo che durasse pochi giorni ho
detto va bene te la puoi cavare con le
stampelle su e giù e abito al quarto
piano
il sensore ho fatto per un po di giorni
quei giorni sono diventati settimane
sono diventati mesi e quindi la
frustrazione cresceva ancora di più
perché potete immaginarvi nell'anno di
preparazione olimpica si trovi a stare
fermo e veramente una frustrazione
incredibile ebbene io ho pensato marty
cioè tu l'hai già vissuta questa cosa la
puoi superare quindi ho cercato di
veramente di fare di ricordarmi come
avevo fatto come avevo superato quel
momento come avevo tirato fuori quelle
energie e tocca voli lei già fatto quel
passo
e allora ho pensato che dovresti solo
stringere i denti solo solo tener duro
perché alla fine lo sai che c'è una
ricompensa e anche se fosse solo un
momento di felicità
vale la pena lottare per quel momento in
più
in tutto questo casino in questa
confusione arriva verso marzo la nomina
a portabandiera per la delegazione
italiana che orgoglio e felicità
intanto dentro io stavo bruciando e
tutti i giornalisti i media giornali che
mi dicevano congratulazioni pacche sulle
spalle strette di mano e io se fossi
sino allo sport ha una cosa fantastica e
mi obbligavano in quei momenti li anche
chiedendomi ma come stai a tirar fuori
con delle parole il mio groviglio che
avevo dentro era obbligata perché
giornalisti sono tremendi è anche
piacevole a volte poter raccontare e
quindi in quei momenti
cosa fai tieni duro come sempre
splendida martin sorridente fino a
quando finalmente a maggio a fine aprile
una dottoressa non trova la soluzione a
questo problema e io torno letteralmente
sui miei passi e quindi è come se avesse
in quel momento ho incontrato nel
nella mia attraversata una piccola oasi
si la prima tappa di felicità e ho
ripreso tutto quanto è
nell'avvicinamento a rio
alla partenza la pressione era sempre di
più fino a quando finalmente siamo
partiti è già sul volo verso il
sudamerica
mi sentivo proprio liberata da questo
fardello no che era il peso delle
pressioni e una volta arrivata a rio
entrò nel villaggio olimpico e mi
ritrovo ancora una volta in quella
situazione che conoscevo da londra 2012
alle precedenti paralimpiadi in questa
bollano che è il villaggio paralimpico
in questo non luogo dove c'è tutto il
mondo e dove tu non devi far altro che
cercare di dare il tuo meglio quindi
dopo pochi giorni la mia prima gara il
salto in lungo
ecco nel salto in lungo io ho
un'avversaria storica tedesca si chiama
vanessa lo è già da maggio quando avevo
ripreso gli allenamenti sapevo che non
avrei potuto batterlo perchè avrei avuto
bisogno di più tempo per raggiungere
delle performance che lei ha già
raggiunto quindi la gara è andata
proprio come me l'ero sognata qualche
giorno prima vi assicuro che l'ho
sognata proprio nei dettagli tant'è che
mi sono svegliata la mattina sudata con
un ipotetica medaglia d'argento già al
collo quindi diciamo che la gara insieme
la sono veramente goduta sfruttando
anche per la prima volta il club del
pubblico cioè l'incoraggiamento e ve lo
faccio vedere
[Applauso]
non è finita qua 466 il mio record
personale felice contento adesso
avvicina il momento più il più aspettato
il più discusso il più desiderato da
tutti quanti e sembrava essere anche il
più ovvio perché sapete i 100 metri la
mia gara quella che preferisco è una
gara in cui o dal 2012 sono imbattuta o
tutti i titoli mondiali europeo record
del mondo e non dico per vantarmi ma lo
dico per rimarcare il fatto che quando
tutti sono abituati a vederti sul
gradino più alto del podio è poi
difficile deluderli e spaventoso fallire
quando tutti ti vogliono ancora lì e che
lo dicono
e te lo ricordano e quanti messaggi non
potete immaginare quanti messaggi mi
sono arrivati l'incoraggiamento e
involontariamente anche tanti sassolini
sono stati messi sulle mie spalle di
aspettative aspettative che pesavano i
però spalle grandi abbastanza da
sostenere tutto ciò è da reggere il
colpo e quindi adesso finalmente è come
li sui blocchi
dopo quattro anni dopo tutto quello che
era successo i comandi max7 ai vostri
posti cronici
io sono pronto
insiste fast and me lei grazie a cir e
carifo reina riserva
bene ne è valsa la pena
credete ma vale la pena merita anche di
essere raccontato un piccolo retroscena
ovvero che questa gara è un po stata per
me anche una sorta di metafora della
vita cioè partenza bomba vado sono prima
tutto va bene vado che è un piacere
a un certo punto non so se vi siete
accorti sui 60 metri sento una
sensazione terribile di perdere la
protesi a causa il sudore e umidità e
quant'altro
in quel momento lì non riesce a pensare
ma in una frazione in secondo penso
martin non puoi fermarti devi resistere
non puoi non poi non puoi fermarti
quindi guardo goffamente alla mia destra
per vedere se arriva la tedesca riguardo
davanti e ho tagliato il traguardo per
prima ce l'ho fatta questo per dirvi
anche che se si vuole raggiungere un
sogno non basta crederci a metà
bisogna crederci fino in fondo ed ecco
che una volta arrivata per prima
di certo un attimo realizzare come
vedete lo faccio così e poi scoppia in
un pianto in un pianto che durerà 20
minuti o tutte le interviste successivi
successiva in cui sono singhiozzanti e
per una volta mi ero anche truccata per
essere televisiva il trucco tutto
sbavato che sbavato ed è anche il
simbolo di una corazza che ho buttato lì
come se mi fosse elevata questo mantello
da supereroe vino dopo aver finito tutto
quanto ecco è questa esperienza mi ha
dato tantissimo e posso dire anche che
io mi sento un semplice granello in
questo deserto in cui siamo tutti quanti
però la differenza
penso che la faccia quando uno non si
arrende al vento e alla bufera che lo
vuole spazzare via
e questa medaglia io la desideravo la
volevo tantissimo non solo per me ma per
tutti quanti perché la vedo come un
segno tangibile di una volontà la
realizzazione di una volontà e anche
come
detonatore nodi conseguenze successive
come un domino e quindi in più con una
medaglia al collo le persone forse
possono capire che le mie non sono solo
parole al vento
ma forse sono proprio passi nella sabbia
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]